so yeah thanks for that I was a student
here at Stanford many years ago as
Michael said we actually were same class
I saw him be part of was it the a
cappella group you were part of Fleet
Street yeah so I saw him do that many
times I studied with a professor named
BJ Fogg here how many people here have
taken a class at BJ Fogg or no BJ Fogg
was persuasive technology lab two or
three okay there's a lab at Stanford
called the persuasive technology lab and
it's basically all about applying what
we know about psychology to make
technology more persuasive so how could
you make technology persuade people to
click on a button or respond to an email
or sign up for a forum or go floss right
and in that class what I learned was all
of the things that essentially all the
levers you have to kind of tweak human
behavior to tweak choice to tweak
attention and there's one class on
ethics so we have this this tool set now
right imagine you're giving this tool
belt which is here or all the ways to
tap into people's psychology right you
have all these levers you know you can
influence these people so what ethical
code should govern the use of that
psychological tool set and that question
has been really interesting to me for a
long time when I was a kid I was a
sleight-of-hand magician and that may be
very interested in basically we don't
see the things that we don't see and
there's all these subtle ways that
people can be misled right without
knowing it and again there's no that
there's ever been this question about
what is the ethics of all of that and as
designers when you go out there in the
world how many people here are like the
king how many people guard in computer
science like computer science students
okay
psychology 1 what am I missing quick
shout outs any other fields mostly
computer science many of you're probably
gonna go out and start companies or work
at technology startups right and you're
going to be in this position where
you're in front of millions of people
you're making something that's going to
get used by millions of people and
whether you want to or not you're going
to be steering them towards certain
kinds of things you're gonna be steering
them to do certain things at their time
and not others and
so I think you know this influence that
we have specifically isolated like in 50
mile radius of where we are right now
and at Stanford is profound and we don't
really talk about what is the fair or
good use of that influence or not and so
I'm going to talk a little about that
today and that was just a little bit of
an intro and I also want to say that I'm
here also to ask you for help with what
I'm gonna talk to you about because this
is kind of like I'll make this metaphor
later but it's kind of like where we
were with organic in 1970 and we're just
starting to realize there's a different
kind of conversation we might want to
have about food I think we're about to
have that conversation with technology
and I'd love your help so I'm going to
talk about three things what I see is
the problem some specific designed sorry
some specific designs principles that
will kind of alleviate some of this and
then also a different kind of system
that can manage this so first what's the
problem so in my life I think a lot
about where my time goes I've always
been kind of vigilant about where my
time goes I took another class in
Stanford a long time ago on
existentialism which profoundly shaped
me we have this one life to live right
and we're given this one ticket with
this one life and where the hell should
we spend our time and I get really
concerned about this because so much of
my time gets slipped away to
distractions I just get sucked into
stuff right if I get a push notification
or the little red badge shows up I'm
just gonna get sucked in and you know if
I get an email like this that I've been
tagged in a photo how many of you've
gotten this email like today some of you
this is one of the most compelling
emails a human being can receive right
because your social acceptance in your
social acceptance of rejection are
essentially on the line so are you gonna
not respond to this email
no of course except you're not just
gonna click see photo I'm gonna spend
the next 20 minutes right this happens
every time or you know I'll pull find
myself pulling to refresh my email and I
pull down to refresh but then 30 seconds
later I'll like unlock my phone and I'll
do it again why why did I do that
is there really like dry even understand
why I did that I mean do I expect that
there's a new email that came in is
there something really that that would
have happened like what's the real
what just examine that for a second why
in the world are we doing that well I'll
give you a hint why this is happening
what are you thinking the United States
makes more money than the entire
industries of movies baseball and game
parks combined in the United States so
the answer is slot machines yeah so slot
machines specifically not casinos slot
machines which is crazy how can that be
possible because it's not like they're
playing with hundred-dollar bills right
people are playing slot machines with
tiny tiny bits of change with coins but
my phone is a slot machine right every
sign every time I check my phone I'm
like playing the slot machine to see
what did I get right every single time
that I pulled a refresh my email I'm
playing the slot machine to see what am
I gonna get every time you scroll a news
feed you don't know what's next on the
page so you're playing the slot machine
to see what's the next thing on the
newsfeed this is operating on something
many of you might know is a variable
schedule reward in psychology is very
very powerful
Pepa leavening and conditioning all the
stuff that you've heard but specifically
there's a book called addiction by
design that Natasha Scholl at MIT wrote
that talks about how slot machines are
so addictive they're actually 2 to 3
times faster to get people addicted or
problematically involve more so than any
other kind of gambling and that people
who are even aware of the dynamics of
slot machines once they understand how
it all works it doesn't break the spell
there's a famous example of a woman
named Rose who's a slot machine addict
and she decides I want to break the
spell so she tries to become a
technician of slot machines and she says
surely if I figure out how slot machines
work and I fix them every day that would
like break the problem but it didn't do
anything she would still go back on her
lunch break and play the slot machines
the rest of the day it's incredibly
addictive and it runs her life and also
say one more thing about this which is
in 2009 I had lunch with Rebecca Cox who
was the first news feed designer of
Facebook newsfeed
and if you many of you may be too young
to remember this but Facebook was not
always just the newsfeed there is a page
that you could go to and it would have a
couple notifications but didn't have the
newsfeed when you first landed there and
she was the designer of it and she was
telling me over lunch that one of the
things that made the newsfeed work was a
hardware innovation a hardware
innovation and I was like what do you
mean hardware there's no Hardware on
this screen you've designed
well she said no it had to do with the
ubiquitous introduction of scroll wheels
on mice and the double finger scrolling
on trackpads
the reason being that when you don't
have to move your hand from its resting
position to scroll you can just scroll
the trackpad like that which is the
exact same thing by the way that they've
done with slot machines they found that
you can get people more into the zone if
you just put a little button there
instead of having a whole lever because
your hand doesn't have to leave its
resting position right so you just
you're hitting the pellet so just to
really emphasize your experience that
technology is so driven by this mechanic
so I want to say this is not a new
problem this is something that many
people historically been have been
thinking about for a long time there's a
great book called amusing ourselves to
death that this guy Neil postman wrote
and he compares these two visions of the
future the dystopian vision of the
future by George Orwell who wrote 1984
and the dystopian vision of the future
by Alice Huxley who wrote brave new
world and he has this great distinction
I want to read to you quickly which is
that what he says what Orwell feared
were those who would ban books
what Huxley feared was that there
wouldn't be no reason to ban a book
because there would be no one who wanted
to read one more well feared those who
would deprive us of information Huxley
feared those who would give us so much
that we'd be reduced to passivity and
egoism Orwell feared the truth would be
concealed from us Huxley feared the
truth would be drowned in a sea of
irrelevance in other words they failed
to take into account man's almost
infinite appetite for distractions I
really take this into account because I
think this is what I've studied the last
10 years is essentially when we say
distractions what we're really failing
it to take into account is psychology
the way that what's just so seductive to
human being psychology that one
shows up we don't have as much choice
right and that's what this is about and
one thing we need to acknowledge is that
this is not appearing in a vacuum we
have what are the systemic forces that
create this well we live in an attention
economy which means that whether you're
building a meditation app to help people
meditate or you're building an
informative news website or you're
building an addictive game you're still
competing for attention you're competing
you win by getting people to spend time
on things you win by being better at
developing a habit at triggering people
at getting them to come back three or
four times in a week so that they
develop a self habit that they then you
know come back on their own and the
thing is there's whole industries that
are set up to teach people how to do
this
BJ fogs class at Stanford books like
capital AG captive ology hooked these
are the you know cortex you've read in
some of these classes and then of course
there's entire people whose job it is
every day to go to work and to find new
ways to get you to come back literally
hundreds of people so when you're
sitting there in front of that screen
and you're thinking I'm not going to
scroll down on the newsfeed today I'm
going to really minimize my time we have
to realize that's your prefrontal cortex
attempting to set a goal that's millions
of years old hardware up against a
roomful of engineers whose job it is to
get you to scroll more right and there's
no evil here just to be really clear
there's nothing that's wrong with this
this is just the system that we've we're
living in right where we're we need to
get people to spend time that's the how
the industry works so and it leads us to
a kind of race to the bottom of the
brainstem to win right because to win
means you have to be better at seducing
psychology right so it's not that I
don't know how many of you know this is
the ALS ice bucket challenge you guys
know that yeah so this is a great social
causes for the ALS you know social cause
but should this be the set of rules that
you're forced to win by right should
this be the game you have to play if you
want to get people to care about a
social costs so it leaves us in this
kind of all-or-nothing relationship with
technology because we're either on and
were connected but then we get
distracted all the time and
10 or we have to turn it off and we
leave our phones at home and we don't we
you know we put it away right but in
other words it's kind of a bad menu
because we're either distracted or we're
missing out on the benefits of
Technology completely and that's a
really kind of bad menu to live by right
let's imagine like being on a diet and
someone's only handing you an option of
burgers or fries right it's just it this
is not enough choice so what we need to
do is we need to restore choice but I
want to say something about where that
choice has to come from because as we
just said there's a bunch of forces that
are so seductive to us that that's
choice is not going to come from
willpower or just better habits right
because we kind of know the limits of
that what we need is better design and
you know in terms of resisting this
stuff even resisting a blinking
notification light or resisting
scrolling when you know that there's you
kind of feel compelled to scroll that
takes energy
everything depletes the sort of
conscious decision making energy there's
a bunch of research by this guy Roy
Baumeister at Florida State University
who's shown that our choice making our
conscious choice making energy is sort
of finite in a day and so if you're
putting choices in front of people
you're depleting the store of conscious
choice making energy that they have
available which means that you know
everything that you consider or resist
is depleting this battery so the more
notifications you're sending people the
more email someone has to receive and
think about right there's a lot of ways
to kind of overload people and so as a
designer you're designing both kinds of
choices you're designing the conscious
choices and how you put those in front
of people but you're also designing
what's left over so when someone's just
running on autopilot and this sort of
unconscious system one mode your design
you're basically choosing for them
whether you want to or not you're
putting the groove lines in the ground
so when people are walking they just
follow the groove line right does that
make sense of this conscious choice
making an unconscious choice making and
you're designing both it is as a
designer you have to make choices like
what choices should I put in front of
you that should be conscious which one
should be automatic that I don't prompt
you for which ones are just the groove
lines of how the world works
and to give you a sense of how deep this
might be you given what we know about
modern psychology you know which
preferences should we honor a Netflix
has a there was a group a Netflix er
there's a guy at Netflix who had studied
the taste profiles of user and I don't
know how many of you remember but
Netflix used to be this service where
you put online what you wanted and then
four days later you got a DVD in the
mail so this is the DVDs in the mail
service for Netflix and what this person
found was that if you took a user who
got DVDs in the mail from the this
version of Netflix and then you
activated them as an instant watch user
so they switched to what to be able to
watch whatever they want instantly what
they found is that the person's taste
profile shifted meaning before they
wanted to watch you know documentaries
or you know action movies or whatever
they were really into and then when they
got instant watch suddenly they wanted
to watch like Family Guy and comedies or
other stuff right so why would that be
the case well in one case you're
choosing for your future self and the
other case you're choosing for your
instant immediate self and it's like
different people it's the same thing as
in behavioral economics where they found
that if you take a person who's really
hungry and you go to the grocery store
when you're really hungry you walk home
home with not just less healthy food but
more food versus if you walk in the
grocery store when you're totally sated
and you're not hungry
so there's not even one consistent human
being to design for there's a multitude
of selves inside all of us and how do we
as technology designers honor or ask or
elicit the values of all of those
different selves that we're designing
for who are we designing for so I want
to bring those up as sort of the frame
for them saying what does it mean then
to design something to be on someone's
team to help them spend their time well
and so our choices are always situated
there's no such thing as just this free
uninfluenced choice there's no such
thing as an influencer choice there's
only choices that are situated or
influenced by a moment and the the way
the framing of the choice the moment of
the choice what what else is surrounding
the context of that of that choice and
our choice is therefore are only as good
as the menus that we put in front of
people to make them and you as the
designers of the technology are the menu
designers you're creating the menus okay
so I'm just gonna look at that so what
are some design principles in the face
of this frame of the problem so one
thing that I want to shift is that when
we're designing products we're not just
designing a product and assuming free
choices that people are just going to
you know Express free choices with the
product we're designing the relationship
that a person has with the product we're
designing the situation that a person
has or is in when they're designing when
they're making choices with the product
so what that means is that I think our
role as product designers we often think
I'm just going to build an app right and
however often they go to the app where
they check the app or they do something
is totally up to the user and I don't
influence that well I'm saying no let's
let's shift that what if we had a
responsibility as designers for the
relationship you have with the product
and to do that we need to acknowledge
the blind spots of psychology we need
acknowledge these real forces that you
know variable schedule rewards or social
acceptance of rejection or the sort of
things that we're not necessarily aware
of that that are driving a lot of the
behavior we have so it's designers we
have to inoculate people in a way or
give them behavioral antibodies for
these these things that show up and so
what I want to talk about is what would
make a good relationship and how do you
design to give people choice over these
aspects of their relationship I'm gonna
talk about a few today I'll try to rush
through them because I want to make sure
we have time for questions so the first
one is being able to bound your
relationship so there's a famous
behavioral economic study where if you
give a bunch of people you ask a bunch
of people to sit down at a table and you
say there's a bunch of soup bowls on the
table soup in them and you just ask
people to sit down and eat and what the
participants don't know is that some of
the bowls of soup actually have a tube
underneath them and as they're eating
it's refilling the bowl with more soup
and so we think that how much soup we
eat is a matter of choice right like I'm
in control of how much I eat and this
study basically showed that it's not
true that basically people who had the
bottomless bowls didn't know when to
stop they underestimated how much they'd
eaten by like 170 calories they seventy
six percent more soup and they were no
more sated or less hungry than the other
so you know and the way you get around
this is alright and the reason I mention
this is because a lot of the technology
we use looks like bottomless bowls right
these feeds that just kind of go on
forever
and they're designed like that for a
reason as we know but the way you fix
this is you give people back a choice
about how big a bowl they want you let
them set the bottom of their bowl you
let them say how big a plate you want
before you go into the buffet you give
them a choice about the medium of the
relationship they're gonna have with
these food choices so what would that
look like with technology well imagine
you showed up in your email this is an
idea and it asks you it took
responsibility for the relationship how
much time you want to spend an email
today and then it was on your team to
spend that time that way right or what
if you could mark a website that you
particularly wish you spent a little bit
less time on and one be more mindful of
your usage and what if you could say hey
I you know I want to mark that website
so when I go there it gives me this
little feedback of how often I've been
there today and how much time I've
actually been there right and maybe the
beginning of the day it asked me how big
a plate size do I want today of that
website that I use a lot and I would say
oh I want 30 minutes and you know the
next time that I go there and I've gone
there past you know maybe it shows up in
yellow so it activates system one
intuitive processing makes me a little
bit more aware of you know what I'm
doing with technology is reflecting back
that that usage to me and then maybe ask
me for a confirmation to go there when
I'm over that that 30 minutes or
something so this is technology that's
taking responsibility for the for the
boundedness of your relationship with it
so another one is timeliness so it's not
just a matter of something being good or
bad it's about well when'd it show up in
my life right there's things that I
really like doing I just don't like
doing them now and there's different
design patterns that reflect this so one
of them is reflected in things like
mailbox or inbox by Google or you can
snooze a message so yes I want to
respond to that email but I want respond
to it later right or if you've used
things like pocket or Instapaper yes I
want to read that article but I want to
do it later so this lets me it gives me
choice over the relationship I have with
things I'm not in this all-or-nothing I
have to read it now or
let it burden me sitting as a tab open
in my browser for two weeks while I know
I'm not going to get to it right so
timing this is another big factor you
can also do it in bash so there's Google
Gmail tabs lets you basically push off
certain categories of email so you can
check your social messages on a
different frequency than you check all
the other stuff these are ways of time
shifting things both individually
manually and in batch so this is a
design principle you can follow another
one is the separate e of a relationship
so this is actually representing the
same Gmail example where you're allowed
to separate out these different types of
things that you're after right right now
with your email unless you're using this
you have to look at everything all at
once you have to you have to you're
forced to consider all these different
parts of your life all in one list right
you're not allowed to separate them or
if you go to Facebook and you are just
interested in going to events right and
looking up an event well you can't just
do that you have to go through the front
door where they where they put the news
feed in front of you right so you're not
allowed to separate so one design
pattern would be to enable people to
separate out the activities or
intentions that they want to do this is
something that mailbox does when you
want to compose a message it separates
out this task enabling you to focus more
on just that but it's an important thing
to consider designing for how can I help
the user separate out the thing they
want to do from the things that they
wouldn't want to do and be more
conscious of that I'll go through that
later related to that is a design
principle which I call intention first
so in the relationship does it ask me
for an intention first before just
offering me the salad bar of or the
sugar dessert bar of everything that it
offers so you know I have this joke
wherever my laptop I often put a little
sticky that says do not open without an
intention all right how do we how would
you make some surface or some product
and intention first product well you
know do you ever open your phone and
just kind of notice you swipe through
two screens swipe back two screens and
turn off your phone you guys do that
this is sort of not an intention first
interface right it's a brows first
dessert base just here's here's some
stuff based interface imagine though or
you rather you go to Gmail to compose a
message
you know you want to compose a message
but then you're not given the ability to
just do that you have to go to the door
way of seeing all your email first right
that's not really an intention first
interface or as we mentioned you have a
need like I need to look up Joe's number
and so you go to Facebook to do that but
then you get sucked into the newsfeed so
these are not intention first interfaces
and so an intention first interface
would be one that controls for the
intention that you have coming in and
also the intention you have going out so
Jesus the person leaked from their
intention when trying to get to the
thing they're trying to do before or do
they leak after so a couple examples of
this are on your phone this is sort of a
combination of habits and design
patterns what I do when I want to launch
an app for example is i unlock my phone
and then I instead of scrolling through
the apps I just pull down and type the
thing I'm looking for because that's
letting me express the intention of what
I want or if you use a voice command you
say you know hey Siri I want to do this
or Google now right it speaks to the
value of these kinds of interfaces
because it lets you express what you
want before you get sidetracked to
something else so this prevents the in
leakage part we're talking about there's
things like spotlight on OS 10 or a
Quicksilver that do this as well this
was an example of that as well if
letting you set an intention first when
you first arrive in your email and I'm
sorry this is that order these are
examples of the the out leakage so
Netflix because they're part of the
attention economy and want to maximize
the intention how many of you have in
the situation where you finish an
episode and it tries to autoplay in five
seconds right so this is an out leakage
because your intention we don't know
what your intention was but it's
certainly pushing more strongly to leak
you into the next thing as opposed to an
interface which bounded your intention
and created a conscious choice or an
active choice there or things like Vimeo
when you go to watch a video on Vimeo it
just shows you the video right there's
not this this you know intentional
sidebar that's trying to take you out it
just focuses on what you wanted to watch
and that's reflected in the incentives
that that Vimeo has and YouTube is a
little bit different because there's the
incentive to keep watching more videos
there's a little bit more out leakage
with with with YouTube and then another
thing that makes a good relationship is
reducing psychic costs or what I call
psychological externalities an interface
peace of mind anxiety free so a lot of
you might feel a lot of times again like
I just got a turn off right I'm gonna
turn off my phone because I'm just can't
have it with all this stuff and of
course you can't do that because you
freak out and say well what if I miss
something important what if that
important phone call comes in and mom
wants to call me before finals what if
you know something happens my kids I
have to be connected so you're always
worried about missing something
important that's a psychological
externality it's this open loop that I'm
going to be worried about until there's
a better design and so it keeps us on
this treadmill and there's different
design features to alleviate this iOS 8
lets you for example say for a given
email thread that you want to receive
notifications on that email thread so
you know that you can basically turn off
all your email notifications by default
then have certain ones that say if
someone is my boss or my you know
girlfriend emails me back on this thread
I want to know about it and you can have
a separate way of getting notifications
on that or you know no they don't check
your email consciously to see if your
boss responded because boomerang has
this option boomerang is a gmail
extension that lets you say if I don't
hear back please boomerang this message
in a week these are different examples
of essentially things that reduce the
psychological externalities or if you're
in a in a you know how many of you go to
dinner with a friend and you know if you
have to leave in like an hour and a half
right except what you do is you leave
your phone there so that every 10
seconds you can kind of check to see is
it an hour and a half yet like you want
to make sure you don't miss your your
time to leave so a different choice
would be to basically set the alarm and
put it away with confidence knowing that
it's going to call you back so it's
moving from a a pole base to a push base
type type model but design you can
design with that in mind and enable
people to disconnect right you can give
them back the freedom and the ability to
disconnect without worried that they're
missing something important and that's
what you know a lot of these Smart Watch
type things are trying to do as well is
basically give you the confidence and
security without the worry of like a the
phantom buzz phenomenon right where
you're worried that you might have
missed something on your phones you have
to pull it out all the time one of the
benefits of having wearable technology
is the idea that you get a salient
notification that you won't miss is
something important comes in that's one
promises of that kind of technology and
then another thing that makes a good
relationship is how good it is
reflecting back to you is it does it
care about showing its impact in your
life so many of the technologies we use
do take on as its responsibilities in
the design the the the need to reflect
back to you what your your relationship
with it is right so in a car
speedometers or Adamo ters what if you
had something like that for your phone
right what if there is something that
when you unlock your phone it gave you
some kind of feedback about your use of
it and when you spiked it it maybe you
know showed you that if this is
something you would want you'd have to
demand that but we have things like that
with speed limits right where they flash
the the flashing speed limit sign we
could do that in browsers where we could
show we could be better at reflecting
back to you where you spent your time
something that design you know in design
of an application that you make you
could do that you can reflect back to
people their use in the omnibox there's
all sorts of examples you could also
reflect back more honestly the costs of
a very of a kind of choice so medium for
example you guys are medium is the
online publishing site they actually
reflect back the reading time so that
you can make a more conscious or honest
choice before clicking on it these are
just different examples of reflecting
back information about what you're about
to do calorie counts on menus in general
reflection can modify choice if it's if
it's integrated into the moment of
choice and one thing to say about this
is things like rescue time if many of
you use it did anybody here know what
rescue time is rescue time is a service
that you install and it basically shows
you a footprint of where your time gets
spent across every application and every
web site and gives you this weekly
report showing here's where you spent
your time last week so we think well
this would be a wonderful way to change
our behavior because if I just saw a
mirror of my behavior then maybe I would
change turns out it's not true it's
because in general again with with
reflection you have to show people their
behavior in the context of the next
choice they're gonna make so if you just
show them this deferred thing that's a
report it's just a report it doesn't
actually change behavior has to be
integrated into the new moment of choice
and then another thing that makes a good
relationship is to have it be value
centric meaning does it care about your
values and organize choices in terms of
what you want so the design principle is
screens should organize choices by what
matters to us it should organize choices
by the values that we hold for our lives
and help frame choices in accordance
with that so what does that look like so
how many of you you might be a little
young for this but some of you might you
know taking international flights and
let's say that you are you know you you
booked a flight on one of these websites
and you find yourself in an airport at
around 11 o'clock at night in some
random layover city for four hours and
you're thinking yourself why didn't I
spend the extra forty dollars on the
other flight it was $40 I'm here for
four hours of what am I really doing
here and Hipmunk is a travel website
that realized this that the people care
about sorting by price obviously but
they also sort about something else
which is what is flying really about is
it just about price or is it about human
values like the agony or the pleasure of
a trip right and so there again we're
only as good as the menus that were
given and if you give someone a menu
that organized choices by the the life
experience that will create that's a
different way to think about the menu
you're putting in front of someone so
ask the deeper question what's the human
value that this choice is really about
how would how would this choice affect
someone's life and friend a choice that
way
another example is like let's say you're
booking a one-on-one with your boss in
Google Calendar you know there's this
little right hand side meeting room
selector so what is a meeting room
selector for well you think it's for
selecting a meeting room but what is a
room selector really for well it's about
what is the most fulfilling way for two
people to catch up right like what just
imagine what the global set of like if
you were just a brainstorm for a second
I have a one-on-one with my boss what
would be the most fulfilling way for the
two of us to catch up and it might be
taking a walking meeting it might be you
know doing a little interactive charades
exercise first or a five-minute
meditation before we get started who
knows but how can the choices that we
put in front of people honor what's at
stake in that interaction or let's say
you
care about exercise and let's say you
could express that that value that you
care about that to various products and
so let's say you're in New York and
you're searching for subway directions
between work and Spring Street and it
gives you the five subway directions and
now in Google Maps it shows you like the
comparison with uber so you can see the
the cost of what it would take to just
drive there but what if you put also on
life's menu the fact that the person
could walk and you show them the
calories that would burn not because
that's what any company was saying was
good for them because they themselves
said they want more exercise in their
life right like as we're rapidly moving
from menu to menu to menu we're only as
good as the the way the menus present
choices to us because we're cognitively
limited we can only see seven plus or
minus two things at a time and so the
features that we make salient in the
choice architecture determine what
people will do or you know again what if
instead of caring about walking you
cared about
sorry not walking or exercise but let's
say you cared about productivity getting
things done well what if it said you
could walk and here's the here's what
that choice would be about you could
actually finish this podcast that you
really wanted to finish and it's a
thirty five minute walk and you've got
28 minutes left
you know that's this is on your team to
live by the values that you have but for
your life so there's a second thing
that's going on here too which is that
we're changing the design question that
we're asking instead of asking the
question how do we help people get from
point A to point B efficiently which is
a value that we automatically inherit
especially in Silicon Valley where we
create technology families created by
engineers and efficiency is the number
one top promoted value behind most
things we do we're asking a different
question which is how do we help people
get from point A to point B well what
does that mean well well is obviously
gonna be defined by them but that's when
I'm trying to hint at so these are
different aspects of what would make a
relationship with the product more
aligned right or you're taking
responsibility not just for the product
but for the relationship that the person
has with it I want to talk about one
more thing in terms of the design which
is designing interpersonal relationships
because this is a big one for anyone
designing chat applications or
email or messaging you're designing the
relationship between two people so let's
walk through the quick example and the
metaphors for this come from marriage
counselling I won't get into that but a
lot of the influences here if you look
at couples counseling in marriage
counseling there's a lot of really
valuable stuff to look at from a design
perspective turns out so let's take an
example of interpersonal chat so where
does it break down so you have these two
people let's say have Nancy on the left
and she's working on that document and
let's say you have John on the right and
he suddenly remembers oh crap I need to
ask Nancy for that document right now
before I forget right so when he has
that thought what happens well he
doesn't really have a choice he needs to
send her that message right now while he
remembers so what does he do he sends it
a message and it blows away her
attention I just bulldozes her attention
and it turns out there's a serious cost
to this it takes us about 23 minutes on
average to resume focus after any
interruption there's a woman named
Gloria market UC Irvine who's done
research for the last ten years on what
she calls interruption science and her
research shows that it takes us about 23
minutes we cycle through two different
projects usually in a break before
getting back to the original thing that
we were doing so these are knowledge
workers
I believe it NASA that she studied this
with the second thing her research shows
is that it conditions people to self
interrupt more frequently so what I mean
by this is if you take a person and you
look at how much they got interrupted in
an hour the next hour they're not
interrupted but their rate of self
interruption has gone up so what appears
to be happening what she believes and
it's not totally proven yet is that the
more external interruptions we get it's
as if it's changing the internal clock
rate of self interruption alright I
don't know about you but hi in my
self-reflection of my behavior feel this
way I feel like my self interruption is
quite high and it goes up the more that
I'm you know distracted by it by other
things so how do you fix this how would
you fix this with design well like a
marriage counselor what a marriage
counsellor does or a couples counselor
is they take two people who may not be
perfectly articulate at expressing their
own preferences and and they're able to
elicit the underlaw
preferences of both people make the
invisible visible and then align this
new visible set of press preferences so
what would that look like with Nancy and
John so let's see the same situation
again there's Nancy on the Left John on
the right and let's say that Nancy this
time can be invited to show that she has
his preference for being focused while
she's working on this document so she
did know that she wanted to be focused
but she didn't have a sense that she she
needed to be invited by the software to
mark that she was focused let's say this
could happen manually or it could happen
automatically by working on a certain
project or opening up a certain
application like a code editor or
something like that and now Nancy John
sorry still needs to interrupt Nancy to
ask her for that document right so what
does he do he opens this window and he
puts up this this little message except
when he hits return it holds the
messages and QS them up and saying we
will send and deliver those messages to
Nancy as soon as she's available again
because she's focused right now so this
gives this new choice to John because he
can now deliver the message and get on
with what he's doing and yet it doesn't
have to interrupt Nancy right now so
we're done right except you're thinking
I would never trust this because I'd be
worried I'd be I'd miss something
important right and you get around that
by knowing Nancy has to know that if
there's something truly important that
the person could always escalate up a
message right so if you just think about
it we're almost changing the default
settings so instead of by default any
message just goes through and and bumps
the person in the head we basically just
which switch from an accidental or
unconscious interruption world to a
conscious interruption
so interruptions still happen but
they're now conscious consciously
created so let's see I'm sorry this is
another example I can I'm gonna skip
this one actually because I'm gonna
leave time for something else
this works for driving as well okay
so but we did a second thing here again
which is we change the design goal of
chat which is instead of saying let's
help people send a message efficiently
that the goal of chat should just be to
deliver the message - instead saying our
design goal as the designers behind this
product is to ask the question how do we
help people communicate with each other
well now the reason this matters is if
this was your design goal just to help
people communicate or so help people
send messages efficiently then if you're
creating interruptions it doesn't really
matter because you're still following
your goal right the interruptions so far
according to your goal you're still
doing your job you designed this thing
people are being sent messages
efficiently it's awesome but it's not
accounting for this other thing we work
we care about - which is interruption so
we upgraded the goal from just this
transaction to the idea of what is
communicating with each other about it's
about two people maybe understanding
each other respecting each other having
a sense of each other's needs or values
and communicating for that that more
human experience so these were some
design principles that have to do the
tension I just wanted to share some of
them and then what I really want to talk
to you about is a new system because
this is part of a much bigger
conversation that we'll get into so to
open that conversation there was a thing
that I helped create about a year and a
half ago if you don't know this is teak
not Han teak not Han is a 90 year old
Zen Buddhist monk and he's a
international spokesperson for kind of
mindfulness and meditation he was
nominated by Martin Luther King in 1969
for the Peace Prize he's been involved
in all sorts of things he's written lots
of books you might have heard of him and
about a year and a half ago he came to
Silicon Valley because he was very
concerned about how technology was
affecting people's attention and how is
affecting people's well-being very very
concerned about it and he gave us this
tour giving talks about just mindfulness
and and when he came to Google he people
who organized his visit knew about this
sort of design ethics attention ethics
work that I was doing and said we will
actually swap out an hour
his existing schedule and give an hour
of his time to you if you can run around
and find all the designers that you can
so is really amazing I got to basically
run around Google and find the top
designers I could and we had the lead
designers of you know glass and search
and Android and some other people and in
a room so imagine you go to room one day
at work and there's you know this
conference room like a normal day except
on one side of the conference room is
just literally nine brown robe Buddhist
monks on one side of the table right and
then the other side are just a bunch of
Technology designers and we had this
talk about what are we really designing
for are we designing just products
redesigning just transactions or are we
designing essentially people's attention
all lives are we designing something
deeper and I always mentioned this
example but as something that came up as
a joke he said in our conversation what
if instead of a spellcheck you had a
compassion check meaning you know cuz
you highlight words in yellow that might
be accidentally understood as abrasive
by the other person not because you're
trying to coerce people but just to make
people more aware and again it goes from
upgrading the goal of you know a
communication client from just being
about delivering a message to asking how
can we enable the most compassionate or
honest or real communication that we can
so you know does this kind of
conversation happen outside of just
design meetings with monks well one of
my favorite examples about this topic is
couchsurfing do you guys know what a
couchsurfing is predated Airbnb it's
actually bigger than Airbnb up until
about a year ago I think and cap surfing
is a free sharing economy of free space
so if you have an extra couch in your
apartment in Palo Alto you can put it up
on couchsurfing and international
travelers who are looking for a place to
stay can find you and then stay with you
for free and it operates entirely on
this this reputation economy it's a
great service so if you went to work and
you're designing couchsurfing what do
you think your goal might be you might
think that the goal would be well if
there's someone looking for a place to
stay the goal metric would be did they
find a place to stay right
find a host but here's where it gets
interesting because that goal would kind
of be like our other goals it would be
like the transactional goal of chat
where we're just delivering a message or
would be like the transactional goal of
the transportation in example we're just
trying to get someone from point A to
point B because the actual goal that
they set for themselves is that they
want to create a lasting positive
experience between two people who've
never met so they said our goal is not
just to match the transaction not just
that two people connected we care about
people having a positive lasting
experience and the way they did that is
they came up with the metric which is
brilliant and a really good friend of
mine named gentleman came up with it and
the way it works is essentially you have
two people let's say there's two people
and they're meeting up in their you know
in Paris or something like that and
let's say they spend four days together
so what they do to count to create this
metric is they say for two people who
are meeting how many days they spend
together so they get the number of days
that two people spend so they take four
days and then what they do is they say
how many hours occurred in those days so
they estimate how many hours would have
been created in this interaction between
two people and then they asked both
people how positive were those hours so
what you're getting is a count of
positive hours okay and then what they
do is they subtract from that all of the
time that people spent on couchsurfing
in hours so what you're left with is
just this new set of positive hours
which they call net orchestrated
conviviality or the net good times that
are created between two people who've
never met and these are hours that would
have never existed
if couchsurfing didn't exist do you get
that like it's so cool right like
there's this there's their success in
terms of new hours on the planet that
two people count as positive
contributions to their lives that
otherwise would have never existed
unless couchsurfing did what they did
today so when you think of this as an
example it's almost like a Gross
National Happiness kind of metric right
can you imagine a whole world that
worked that way right can you imagine if
every service you used if every
technology you used
had a metric that would basically
counted success in terms of net positive
contribution to your life and they
measure themselves that way so instead
of you know dating services that count
their success in terms of swipes left
and right which is currently like a
billion a day what if like tinder met
measured their success in terms of the
number of people who found what they
were looking for right
it didn't just try to maximize swipes
per day what if a professional network
like LinkedIn instead of counting
success in terms of connections that
were added between two people like
engagement metrics or how much time
people spent or how many messages got
sent
what if they measured the number of
people who found jobs that they were
glad to get just the Madaba they were
glad to get right because that's what I
mean or whatever people find fulfilling
out of LinkedIn but the net positive
contribution to their life so you can
imagine like what if the whole world was
totally on your team to help you live
according to what you look matter to you
but to do that your publican can we also
need a new system because our current
system is measured on time spent the way
that you raise funding from the venture
capitalists and Sand Hill a few blocks
from here is you show them your success
or your growth in terms of time spent
you show them I have more usage today
than I had yesterday I have more users
they're logging in more often I get them
to stay longer right so this is going
against that it's a different metric so
how would this work well you'd have to
do it like we've done it in other
industries where we said we have to
value these actors in a different way we
did that once with organic right where
we said prior to organic in agriculture
there was this race to the bottom of the
cheapest price right so if there's two
farmers trying to make apples and
they're putting them out there and one
farmer says you know I don't want to put
pesticides on my apple without the label
organic he's just a 75 cent Apple and
his competitors are a 25 cent Apple so
no one's gonna buy the 75-cent Apple but
when they say no no this is a different
kind of Apple it's an organic Apple then
people can value it differently it can
be valued in a different way it's just
like the b-corp movement if you know
about that or LEED certification where
we said this this is a bill
that's not just about the cheapest price
or the best you know situation it's
about the the green values that stand
behind the building what kind of
sustainability certification does it
follow and how do we value it
differently by giving it a kind of label
well what if we had something like that
for technology where the actors could be
labeled and measured in terms of their
net positive contribution to people's
lives so that they were rewarded for
caring about caring about you and you
know the reason I'm here is because
that's just this is not a conversation
that we're happening having right now
right we're having this we said I've
invisibly live in this attention economy
and everyone's competing for attention
and we're we should start asking the
question is this is this good right are
we are we creating the net positive
contribution in people's lives that we
want to and doing that would amount to
moving from an entire economy that's
measuring success on time spent to one
that's measuring success on time
well-spent and that's what I want to
leave you with before we open up for
questions which is 15 minutes so thanks
a lot of questions always you know my
son doesn't like to watch like a movie
with makers he wants to sit there with
this computer also like a lot of people
here are doing you will show you two
things and I'm like well you're not
watching the movie you're not getting
any enjoyment of watching the movie if
you're sitting there with your computer
and I think that's the better way to
watch it is just watch the movie sure
enough now I find myself watching you
know sitting with my phone and playing
my whatever and no you know this what
I'm going to tell them I don't want to
be so tough I mean I just so get what
you're saying here it's just so
addictive and I've now changed that's
like my breath my value of that is just
that I had which is just watch the movie
do one thing and do it enjoyably well I
find will now kind of enjoy like doing
two or three things instead of just
watching the movie and I'm unhappy with
the way it's going yeah right well I
think what it I just to be really clear
because if somebody like think that I'm
there's a normative argument here that
I'm saying that like mono tasking is the
only way or people shouldn't do this so
they should do this if not what's going
on here we're just the idea is just what
do we feel good about on retrospect like
you know some behavior some of the
things we do with technology we feel
great about it later but like you're
saying some things just don't feel good
and we wish we're doing that as much and
we're not saying that we should stop
people from doing that we're just saying
how could technology be more on your
team when you feel that way so that you
get the behavior that you want and
recognize that we're in this sort of it
takes two to tango type relationship and
we need you know we need some help more
questions and also as I said there's
also different so what are you system I
want a novice whether you system I one
for themselves they call so we decide
how kind of creative process right what
some reason so it's a great question I
think right now there's an
underrepresented we have we
a very narrow idea of what a user wants
the way that Valley tends to treat what
people want is just what you click on
so what you click on a lot is what we
treat that is what you want so if you
come to an app really frequently we
assume that's what you want as opposed
to that's a kind of a I'm seizuring out
my thumb is just hitting stuff right the
the distinction I wanted to create on
the Netflix example is just that there's
a more holistic picture of a user and
then if you sample at the moment that
they're doing something versus right
after they did something versus
retrospectively looking back on their
behavior you get different answers right
but to do that we have to have a
different model of self where instead of
seeing a user as one person with static
preferences we have to acknowledge not
that we have a problem which is that
we're different people at different
times and that the the person that we
become is is partly the invitation
that's created by our environment so as
designers we're creating the invitation
that causes one person or one set of
preferences to emerge and we could do
better to get a more holistic sense so
one of the projects that we wanted this
is sort of an independent by the way
this this time well spent project like
an organic label for for tech one of the
projects is actually to collect that
retrospective signal so what how do
people feel on retrospect you know after
a week looking back in a you know
industry standard mirror version of
their behavior some people feel
wonderful about their use of certain
things and some people feel like a wish
you know part of their use they wish
they didn't do so that's not a direct
answer to your question but that's the
more like that's the conversation to
create surveys I mean so casual thing
actually does an initial follow-up of
asking you to rate on different
variables and they get it they get a
pretty high response rate because the
people who use couchsurfing are actually
part of the community and they view it
as their responsibility to do it it's
not a reputation economy the second
thing that they do is they they confirm
so if you say that you stayed with in
Paris for four days and you had this
positive rating now six months later
they ask you again actually and they
just say did you still feel like that
was valuable and what they found is like
some of people's most rewarding
experiences on couchsurfing were things
they didn't
get about in a moment but felt really
good about later and I think like this
conversation is opening up a much bigger
topic which is what's the moral North
Star of design is it happiness so we
just try to put smiles on people's faces
for their whole life or are we trying to
create a meaningful experience and what
is meaning well it's not just that on
retrospect people feel great I mean
there's this balance between in the
moment positive experience you know
immediately after positive experience
and then retrospective positive
experience so it's a much bigger
conversation and deals with psychology
and behavioral economics in a bunch of
other fields that are looking at the way
that our perception of changes across
emotion they're watching health yeah
think about that and concern about that
and using so you guys understand
basically finding different ways of
extracting a signal that's implicit
whether it's galvanic skin response or
heart rate variability or stress or
something like that I'm very interested
in that I would like to see more people
you know try I'm these things get really
tricky right because if you if you do it
wrong then you come off as a nanny
you're saying don't do this thing that
you want to do and so if you're ever
wrong or saying you're stressed out when
I'm like no I'm not just let me do what
I'm doing right there's that there's
this tricky thing where you have to it's
it's subtle the way that you you have to
bring people so I'm not sure how
optimistic I am about those things but I
think they should be researched and
looked into for sure good question sorry
so it seems like the succession about
games just to spend time and to kind of
new things is fueled a lot by an
advertising business model and I'm
wondering to what extent can these
design principles kind of exists
if it's advertising driven or whether we
really need to think of a different
business model to encourage more kind of
meaningful design yeah it's a it's a
great question so time spent as a metric
for success so he used to just be
impressions like you know pageviews so
it just like did people land on pages do
people land on rectangles and then
recently the metric has evolved to be
more specifically about engagement
there's two reasons for that one is that
engagement serves as a proxy for people
liking something so if the engagement is
up it's not that it's making more money
from that but it's a proxy for value
people are loyal or value this app or
this service more because they're
spending a lot of time on it
the problem is when people mistake the
proxy for the real thing like that that
especially in large organizations where
you have thousands of people just
optimizing to metrics then the kind of
reason behind the metric the fact that
it was a proxy for something else that
gets lost and instead people's bonus
depends on increasing that metric from
Neph what it is now to when it needs to
be so this one so one reason is this
sort of proxy for how much people value
things that's because that's how
investors look at it the public stock
market looks at it things like that the
other side is to do with time spent
based advertising in which by squeezing
out more minutes from people's lives
looking at rectangles you can always
make a little bit more money and that
sets up a little bit of a perverse
incentive right and so I think it calls
into question you know there's different
ways of dealing with that existing forms
of advertising can become more
profitable and we can decide that we
just don't want to undoubtedly grow on
time spent and it's like people's time
away but I think that there's a deeper
thing going on here which is that the
the products that sit between you and
these things that demand your attention
could do a better job of helping you
spend your time the way you want to and
then
so specifically a browser and a mobile
phone Arnon conflict of interest
platforms and they sit between you and
all the websites that you browse and
they sit between you and all the apps
that want your attention and they can
help you sort your attention more
according to what you care about that
makes sense we funded by advertising
which is usually a distracting away from
what you wanted some screens on mobile
phones are not funded by advertising and
browsers are not funded by advertising
right I mean they serve different
strategic purposes right like for
example you know there's ads on Gmail
there's not as on the new version of
inbox and people think that oh like
that's because it needs to be you know
they extract money from every page view
of a Gmail add or something like that
and it's it's it's not usually the way
it seems but you have questions correct
me if I don't understand this correctly
so time well-spent for me a big part of
it means building healthy habits good
habits but a lot of times like good
habits are hard to build just like blue
gym it's just really hard for you to get
there but after the exercise always feel
good I mean be a park motto the harder
it is like the harder something is the
harder it is for people to take action
to do it right what wondering what's
your thoughts on that
yes so for example there's probably I
don't mean to focus the conversation on
apps but like there's probably some app
out there that's really good at people
putting and putting people into a people
who want to work out more into a local
group that goes like twice a week you
know like a walking group or a gym group
or something like that but that app
today would not get rewarded by app
stores wouldn't get a lot of downloads
because it doesn't spread virally
wouldn't get a lot of funding from
venture capitalists wouldn't be able to
hire the best teams wouldn't get the
press so no one would know about it and
so that it's systematically under
rewarded by the economy even if it was
really good at helping people get to the
gym so what you would want is a review
that says oh this thing is really good
not at just being an app that works well
but it's really good at actually
achieving me
outcome of helping people go to the gym
this is still hypothetical but let's
let's say there is this app that's
really good at putting people into some
group and getting people in the gym this
review would help put premium shelf
space up so that that app can be
rewarded for doing good as opposed to
today where it's measured on this time
spent thing it's not going to be
rewarded does that make sense okay how
is this concept being received in Google
internally like with place or potential
you do something like that
this is super this is more this is not
Google this is just independent yeah
ideas but I bet people in Google I think
care about these values a lot and it's
super early I think part of the reason
I'm here is to create more of a public
conversation that's a consumer-driven
conversation set there's more demand for
something like this because until
there's that demand it's hard to
prioritize it from a big company
perspective yeah nidia you put together
this contest where you're talking about
you maximizing these long-term long-term
relationships as opposed to sort of the
twitch egoless like swipe a plane swipes
and I can easily see outcomes where you
know maybe we said we think about and we
run some numbers we realize that the
best way to actually maximize the number
of long-term relationships is to
maximize for twitchiness right and so I
like what are we do in that kind of
scenario right it's like we are helping
more people be happier but we are sort
of burning through a lot of people in
the meantime totally yeah this is like a
consequentialist effect if the outcome
of all the twitching this does get you
that then should you do it right um I
think more important than that is just
that people aren't even having a
conversation right now they don't view
it as a trade-off as opposed to just it
just must be good for people so that
tends to last would be a lack of
consciousness about creating the
twitchiness this where genius has
counted that success or is counted as
making the world more open and connected
or counted as creating long term
relationships when it's not necessarily
that so I know it's sort of a cop-out
answer but I think there's different
ways of thinking about systems like that
like your you could be given some
allowance or something like initial you
know this sort of a an initial period
where we message you more or something
like that and then there's like a
catalog for ages
with that marriage is this why for
something like this I don't know
something period where you you you can't
put up more right because they're
pervading bring them would take that
example so people need to set a pool of
people but they're matching with
frequently you have to get a bidding on
pool even then find some people for them
so there's probably some initial period
where you can ask more of them and then
once you have that pool you can do
better - then like actually get them out
vii need those people more questions
right now if we could because this is a
big problem at different email overload
and time management right how do we all
express our support for the yes okay so
no is not that was awesome actually and
it's so good to hear that if you guys
I mean I'm I came here because this is
literally a public conversation trying
to recruit help from people so one thing
we're doing is there's a redesigned a
we're gonna redesign a bunch of screens
and according to some of the design
principles you saw here and it's
actually a different methodology that my
collaborator in Berlin who's coming to
town for so April 25th it's on a
Saturday there's a Facebook event that's
linked there you can check that out what
we want to do is basically it's almost
like a lower cost way of showing the
world of different kinds of screens
could exist and we can show people that
there's a different way that email could
be designed their home screen could be
designed if I had more time I'd show you
some of those examples that's one way
the other thing is this let's see well
anyway this time we'll spend that I oh
there's a place to add your email
unfortunately we don't have anyone
coordinating and organizing the
different ways to get people involved
but you know there's a bunch of
different projects one is we'd like to
create an independent certification like
organic so for different kinds of
categories of platforms with its
browsers you could have you follow
certain set of set of criteria if you're
a home screen does a 7 insider criteria
you can follow if you're a notification
type screen there's a different set of
criteria you could follow so trying to
create more common standards there's
this reviews database where we basically
gather long term reviews retrospect
reviews of what people find time
well-spent for different values so we
need engineering and other help with
that these are the early stages of these
projects so if you're interested to get
involved actually come talk to me
afterwards as well but this is the place
you can add your name and there's a TED
talk that has a lot of this content on
it and it's on this website so another
thing you can do is just share that and
create more conversation with people
around you if you want a lightweight way
of getting involved you know I didn't
know if you're going off into a company
after this like ask the question to the
people you're working with I mean bring
these issues up right a lot of people
here are either interning or we're gonna
be working or are working now and then
v's these companies and you can bring up
this conversation and have it you know
have a different conversation about it a
lot of this stuff was you know wisdom
2.0 talk that has more detail the TED
talks a little bit more fluffy so if you
want to share that one they're on my
website and they're good conversation
starters
you